[Música]
[Aplausos]
podéis por favor levantarme la mano
todas y todos aquellos que no hayáis
visto pornografía en vuestra vida y no
estáis pensando en hacerlo nunca
porque hay quien dice que esto es algo
malísimo que esto es lo peor que puede
hacer una persona y yo la verdad es que
desde aquí no veo mucho pero no veo
muchas manos levantadas sin embargo en
un momento actual con mujeres de todo el
mundo denunciando abusos y con
movimientos como el meet you en redes
sociales de cuántos casos de agresión
sexual habéis oído hablar que ocurrieran
dentro de la industria probablemente de
pocos o incluso de ninguno y eso quizás
se deba en parte a la influencia del
trabajo que gente como yo hemos hecho
por la industria lo que os voy a contar
hoy es el testimonio de varias mujeres
que han sido agredidas sexualmente y
explotadas sexualmente en este negocio y
también es mi experiencia propia por
hacer algo muy parecido a esto he tenido
que aparecer escoltado por la policía
porque en ese momento estaba amenazado
todo empieza cuando tenía 21 años
acababa de terminar el grado de
periodismo y mi primer trabajo oficial
fue el de escribir en nombre de figuras
importantes para la industria colaboraba
con un grupo editorial de tirada
nacional que llevaba varias revistas
eróticas y para que os hagáis una idea
del trabajo que hacía
una de las cosas que escribí y que se me
quedó grabada fue como ser madre y
actriz porno al mismo tiempo y en esa
columna en realidad estaba hablando de
mi maternidad no sé si me habéis visto
bien pero no hace falta fijarse mucho
para ver que eso era mentira sin embargo
no eran mentiras inocentes respondían al
interés de lavar la cara de la industria
pornográfica porque porque necesitaban
renovar las caras necesitaban caras
nuevas ahí dentro y esto se conseguía
escribiendo principalmente dos ideas la
primera que aquí se gana un dinero muy
fácil y la segunda es que esto esté
libertad te hace sentirte sexualmente
liberada a participar en el porno de
esta forma se conseguían dos cosas
la primera era presentar el porno como
una alternativa laboral perfectamente
viable para el público femenino y para
el público masculino se presentaba como
un consumo más ético en comparación
quizás con la pornografía más machista
que se producía supuestamente en los 80
pero con el tiempo me fui adentrando más
y más y fui viendo cómo eran los rodajes
y me di cuenta de algo nada de lo que yo
estaba contando era verdad y tenía muy
poco de cierto también en lo que nos
cuenta el famoso salón erótico de
barcelona
por ejemplo había tirones de pelos había
golpes violencia y en general un montón
de acciones que evidentemente no habían
sido pactadas no estaban consentidas
os voy a poner algunos ejemplos
una vez conocí a una chica que me contó
como una productora le había ofrecido
drogas para soltarse en un rodaje y ella
las tomó y lo que sucedió después fue
que empezaron a darle temblores
y empezaba a tener escalofríos y no
llegó un punto en el que no se pudo
grabar la escena la dejaron en un sofá
en lugar de llevarla al hospital porque
la productora no quería tener
consecuencias y no quería tener ningún
tipo de responsabilidad sobre ello y
aquello no se denunció otra vez
en un rodaje conocí a un productor de
una importante productora nacional y yo
estaba tomando notas y de repente lo vi
[ __ ] la cámara con una mano y con la
otra bajarse los pantalones y meterse
dentro de la escena a participar pero
aquello no había sido pactado
previamente simplemente ese tolero
una vez también vi a un grupo de chicos
que habían acudido pagando a un casting
porno para ser actores porno y
se habla mucho de las analíticas de
sangre dentro de la industria pero lo
que yo vi fue que le sacaban una gotita
de sangre del dedo eso no te dice
absolutamente nada como mucho el azúcar
que puedas tener
en ningún caso te dice las enfermedades
de transmisión sexual que puede tener
una persona pero es que aunque fuera así
aunque esa analítica no nos lo dijera no
se esperó el resultado se sacó la gota
de sangre y se pasó directamente a
grabar y sobre este mismo tema sobre las
analíticas hace tiempo hubo una especie
de pánico por un posible brote de vih
dentro de la industria
quise saber qué había de cierto y
pregunté a una actriz porno entrevista
con ella os voy a leer textualmente su
testimonio
te puedo decir que he contraído más
enfermedades en el porno que fuera de él
porque trabajando de escort siempre lo
hago con preservativo y en el porno no
es posible en el porno tienes que creer
que la otra persona no ha follado con
nadie sin condón por ahí
la supone el responsable de que se haya
hecho las analíticas pero a la mayoría
de los actores les da igual
y ellas que podían hacer si además
muchas de estas cosas se eliminaban del
montaje final y nos llegaban a vuestras
pantallas y van a quejarse y van a
protestarle al director o al productor
no nada de eso aquí si haces ruido
probablemente acabes en una situación
mucho peor en la que estabas es muy
difícil morder la mano que te da de
comer cuando no hay otra alternativa
pero de eso de precisamente de no haber
otra alternativa es de lo que os quiero
hablar más adelante
por mi parte no podía seguir mirando
hacia el mismo lado
o sea no podía mirar para otro lado lo
que hice fue alejarme de la industria
reunir todo el material que pude
documentándolo y mandárselo a medios de
comunicación nacionales para que
elaboraran su propio contenido e
iniciarán una investigación
lo que pasó fue que lo que pasó fue voy
a hablar claro no se nos hizo ni [ __ ]
caso y perdonad que usted dice estos
términos pero es que fue bastante
impactante ver cómo se ignoraba aquello
tan grave así que no tire la toalla y lo
que hice fue utilizar todo ese material
para escribir mi propio libro que colgué
online gratuitamente se llamaba escupe
lo
y era una especie de contrapropaganda
frente a toda esa propaganda que había
estado haciendo para la industria
resultó que se descargó un total de
10.000 veces en dos semanas
y entonces si como sucede en esta
sociedad del pelotazo cuando algo algo
hace ruido empezaron las entrevistas y
el interés de los medios y sonaba bien
no pero espera porque cada vez que un
medio mencionaba escape lo recibían
presiones desde dentro de la industria
para retirar ese contenido y algunos
hasta acababan cediendo pero es que
además yo recibí amenazas mi círculo
cercano recibió amenazas el servidor
donde estaba alojado el libro recibió
ataques informáticos y nuestras redes
sociales fueron cerradas que era nuestra
nuestra única forma de difusión querían
que escupe lo desapareciera a cualquier
costa y casi lo consiguen pero resultó
que una editorial después de tanto ruido
con las amenazas y con el retirar
contenido dijo oye que contendrá este
libro y nos ofreció un contrato en papel
escupe lo salió impreso cuando parecía
que todo se había perdido y por fin
con el libro impreso podríamos hablar de
prostitución encubierta dentro de la
industria pornográfica de la violencia
del fraude fiscal o en realidad de todas
esas amenazas que silencian todas todas
estas situaciones negativas el libro
apareció en el confidencial en público
en radio televisión española en la sexta
e incluso internacionalmente tuvo un
hueco en un documental de la bbc
pase un año presentando la investigación
y entonces tanto las informantes como yo
elegimos continuar por dos vías
distintas una de ellas era la de la
concienciación en la que hablábamos al
público general de lo que había detrás
de las cámaras del porno
la segunda era de denuncia y colaboramos
con la policía y los juzgados para bueno
dejar constancia y denunciar esas
agresiones sexuales el problema es que
como con los medios no se nos hizo ni
[ __ ] caso y es que resulta que cuando
firmas un papel una agresión sexual se
convierte en algo discutible o al menos
eso parecía
cuando los pornógrafos se defendían en
estos contratos para para no tener
consecuencias legales una vez los
habíamos señalado
en este periodo en este año colabore en
ponencias que tendrían unos diez
ponentes
el precio de todo aquello en honorarios
sería si sumamos todos unos tres mil
entre tres mil y cinco mil euros a lo
que habría que sumar viajes y estancias
en hotel más la organización también
pero es que por otro lado otra de estas
mujeres y solamente si cumplían los
requisitos reciben 400 euros de ayuda al
mes
esto significa que lo que estaba pasando
es que en un día nos estábamos
fundiéndolo que esta mujer podría estar
utilizando durante un año para buscar
una alternativa a su situación
en estos espacios además nunca sé
nunca se oían sus voces no se les
invitaba siempre tenía un matiz quizás
demasiado ideológico y se hablaba en su
nombre por ejemplo se solía defender
mucho que uno todas las actrices porno
han sido sexualmente agredidas
independientemente de lo que ellas digan
dos que todas las actrices porno
necesitan ayuda para salir pero no
pueden participar en la solución y tres
que todas que todas las actrices porno
han sido alienadas por un sistema
proxeneta que les hace justificar su
situación lo cual según este discurso
las convierte en víctimas pero también
en enemigos
pero en esto de hablar en su nombre
realmente las asociaciones algunas
tenían cierto papel
anna de 22 años era una estudiante
universitaria que se mudó a una ciudad
más grande y en un entorno más abierto
entro en un grupo de experimentación
sexual
hasta aquí todo era voluntario y en ese
entorno conoció a una pareja de
productores porno
loft le dijeron se le acercaron y le
dijeron oye por qué no sigues haciendo
esto mismo pero además ganando dinero
y ella aceptó y la experiencia fue
horrible os voy a ahorrar los detalles
con lo que os he contado antes pero ana
quiso denunciar y um y esto llegó a
oídos de una asociación y le dijeron
puedes podemos ayudarte te podemos abrir
espacios en ciudades y en universidades
para que cuentes tu historia y además
vas a cobrar por ello las condiciones
que le pusieron eran estas tenía que dar
la mitad del dinero que ganase dando
esas charlas a la asociación además
tenía que defender que la única
alternativa frente a aquellos abusos
era la abolición absoluta de la
industria del sexo algo así como
prohibir también la pornografía también
tenía que decir que había tenido unas
secuelas psicológicas gravísimas tras su
paso por la industria y por supuesto se
tenía que mostrar muy arrepentida de
haber grabado porno
anna no se veía muy representada en esto
al final era su historia era la
protagonista podría contarla a su manera
y así lo propuso
y la asociación se negó y la descarto
anna no recibió ningún tipo de ayuda y
su voz no se ha escuchado en ningún lado
estábamos realmente ayudando a estas
mujeres o estábamos hablando en su
nombre y nos estábamos beneficiando
colectivamente e individualmente
a dónde iba todo el dinero público
destinado a ayudar a estas personas y a
la prevención después de mi viaje por
las cloacas de la industria del porno os
puedo dar una idea muy clara
no he conocido nunca a ninguna mujer que
haya entrevistado que haya recibido
ayuda para salir de esta industria
pero podría podría pasarte a ti porque
en realidad a diferencia de la
prostitución de la que oímos más los
abusos en la pornografía no pasan a
mujeres migrantes que no conocen el
idioma los abusos en la pornografía
ocurren a cualquier chica joven 'in
situ' en una mala situación económica
podría pasarte a ti a tu hermana a tu
compañera de clase o podría estar
pasándole a la chica que está al otro
lado de la pantalla
hay que preguntarse siempre a quién
beneficia a quien beneficia por ejemplo
que no salga adelante la investigación a
los pornógrafos a toda esa gente que
estaba ganando mucho dinero sin tener
ningún tipo de consecuencia legal por
los abusos que se cometían pero también
a quien como a quién beneficiaba que no
se cuestionará el dinero público a todos
los intermediarios entre los cuales yo
me podía incluir a toda esta gente que
estaba ganando dinero con la situación
lanzando mensajes alarmistas impulsando
una agenda política pero sin proponer
una solución real que beneficiará a
estas mujeres
nunca beneficia a las afectadas
hay documentales hemos visto hay
entrevistas y siempre salen con la cara
emborronada escuchamos su historia pero
nunca sabemos qué pasa después con ellas
el problema además es que hay una
relativa facilidad para acceder a la
financiación cuando tienes este tipo de
proyectos pero ellas tienen dificultad
para acceder a la financiación para
conseguir una ayuda económica que les
permita salir
y aquí viene la parte de la alternativa
la única alternativa que hay realmente
pasa por esa financiación pública si se
está empleando
una especie de show sobre esta temática
luego realmente las víctimas que no
están presentes no tienen ningún tipo de
dinero de fondos a los que recurrir por
lo tanto se quedan olvidadas y nosotros
desde nuestras casas todos los que no
habéis levantado la mano que podemos
hacer pues es relativamente fácil
podemos ser más responsables con aquello
que estamos consumiendo y no me refiero
solamente a la pornografía sino también
a todas las ideas que se nos dan al
respecto por ejemplo
porque estoy recibiendo en mi facebook
este fantástico reportaje de una chica
joven de 20 años que me cuentan que se
ha forrado grabando porno o porque en el
momento en el que más se está hablando
de abusos sexuales parece que la
industria del sexo no existe nos parece
un poco raro o cuando lleguéis a casa y
buscas en google sobre este tema no os
parecerá raro que siempre hablen las
mismas personas y nunca lo hagan quienes
lo han sufrido
si nadie se hace realmente las preguntas
adecuadas nada va a tener porqué cambiar
tenemos que desarrollar un espíritu más
crítico que nos permita distinguir
cuando se nos está vendiendo la miseria
ajena disfrazada de una causa justa en
beneficio del intermediario pero no de
la víctima muchísimas gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]